hey youtubers is Charlie and since it's
been a while since I've done a bonus
Doctor Who video and the channel
is airing this new special on April 18th
I thought it'd be fun to do my top 10
scary classic Doctor Who episodes so the
horror channel is doing this special a
bunch of really classic horror episodes
but you can also get them all on Hulu
and Netflix so even if you don't get the
horror channel you should be able to
watch them all also quick heads up I
have to travel this weekend I'm going to
Las Vegas for my brother's bachelor
party so I might do like a fun bonus
video using my cell phone but I will be
instagramming the out of Vegas so
you can follow me there if you want to
see fun stuff I will be back in time to
do all my Game of Thrones videos on
Sunday though so don't worry about that
also before we get into my list I need
to mention the two new cast members
they've announced since my last Doctor
Who video it's Ben Miller and Keeley
Hawes they're both villains and we don't
know if they're going to be in multiple
episodes or just one episode but they're
going to be super evil and super awesome
I sure so we can talk about them more in
another video so let's talk some scary
classic whoo so this will be my top 10
episodes and since a lot of them were
inspired by really classic sci-fi
stories I'll try to list as many of
those as possible too in case you want
to read them so here we go number 10
deadly assassin the image people most
associated with this episode is the husk
you know form of the master
nightmare-inducing
all by itself but the episode invoked
this really big plot to siphon off
regeneration energy from the I harmony
and this Manchurian Candidate
presidential race on Gallifrey just in
general a really good meta mashup of
other really awesome stories here's
actually a list of some of those other
shows and movies that they paid homage
to in the episode North by Northwest
awesome classic Hitchcock Sherlock
Holmes in the empty house and a couple
of Star Trek original series episodes
including the arena and shore-leave
supposedly it's also one of the only
classic who episodes to not feature a
companion number nine robots of death
the robots in this story really reminded
me a little of the clockwork robots and
girl in the fireplace a human basically
gets raised by robots and eventually
just thinks of them as superior you know
not only do they look super creepy
there's this really horrible moment when
the doctor gets stuck in a storage room
that's slowly filling with sand the
episode was actually inspired by some of
my favorite classic sci-fi stories like
Frank Herbert's dune which is just
amazing Isaac Asimov's I Robot not the
shitty Will Smith version either
and Arthur's Seat Clark's follow the
moondust you can't really go wrong with
some of those authors but it is pretty
scary to think of being killed by beings
that you have been worshipping your
whole life so I guess that might also
scare you off having children to number
eight pyramids of Mars a great zoo Tech
episode I actually saw that a couple of
you guys said you really wanted this
character to come back at some point but
there's this really awesome line in the
episode that stands out where subduct
says your evil is my good i am sooo tech
the destroyer where i tread i leave
nothing but dust in darkness because
it's a mummy story there's a lot of
mythological influences like the classic
hammer mummy films you know hg wells and
even some north mythology you know loki
prison shout out one of my favorite
things about classic Doctor Who episodes
is because you know action and CG
sequences are so expensive you know
special effects are so expensive they
had to make dialogue so much better thus
you get you know the crazy awesome evil
suit tech speeches one of the best bad
guys ever it also involves a lot of evil
robots
I feel like Doctor Who is always trying
to tell us not to trust robots other
than k9 let me know which robots do you
think there are in the Doctor Who
universe that we actually can trust you
know the tesselecta is kind of like a
robot but it's piloted by humans so it's
not really self-aware number seven
terror of the Zygons if you didn't know
them from Tom Baker's runt then you
definitely know them from the fiftieth
anniversary since there are
shapeshifters you know I always think of
them as like invasion of the Body
Snatchers which is just another great
sci-fi horror story the episode was
actually also inspired by the private
life of Sherlock Holmes I always love it
when Sherlock and Doctor Who crossover
if you haven't seen the episode then
watch it then watch the 50th anniversary
again because there are so many nice
callbacks it's so much more fun to watch
Doctor Who when you understand the real
a classic references number 6 tomb of
the Cybermen really my only second
Doctor story in the list but another
Egyptian mythology mummies story I'm
sensing another pattern don't trust
robots don't trust pyramids and maybe
riddles too what is it about uncovering
ancient knowledge that always makes
things go horribly wrong a scientist
just wants to learn a little bit about
Cybermen and all the crazies come out of
the woodwork to join the expedition if
you really want to get meta though you
should watch curse of the Mummy's tomb
the classic film because it was the
primary inspiration for this story
number five the Damon's
into Jon Pertwee's years there's
actually a ton of scary stories during
his run but this one actually kind of
reminds me of the weeping angels and the
beasts just visually other big red flags
for the doctor in this episode are
there's a town called Devil's end the
master gets involved with black magic
and then tries to take a bunch of
demonic powers the main character aside
from the doctor and the master is all
was actually really interesting and
tragic I don't know how they bring him
back just based on the way the episode
ended but he really stands out as one of
the better classic who monsters one of
the more powerful - here's actually a
couple more stories that inspired the
episode village of the Damned start
tricks who mourns for donnas and there's
even another sherlock shout out
elementary my dear benton number four
genesis of the Daleks early Tom Baker
meets Davros you can't go wrong it's
actually also a really awesome scar Oh
based episode in case you've never seen
the homeworld of the Daleks I feel like
most people today just associate them
with their current form but in this
episode you actually get to learn about
the humanoid race they descended from or
evolved from I guess depending on how
you look at it this is also one of those
other really awesome Frankenstein themed
episodes where by you know an evil
scientist or a scientist in general is
just killed by his creation here's a big
question though if doctor who had kind
of continued with that Frankenstein
theme and done bride of the Daleks who
would they've gotten to play the lady
Dalek would it be just like an Elsa
Lanchester Dalek then just be so creepy
number three terror of the Autons
another totally great unit story that
was also a master story it also involves
a bomb inside unit headquarters just
like the 50th anniversary so you know
how some people are afraid of clowns
well this actually gives circuses and
carnival folk a really bad name - one of
the things I really loved about the
episode though was how the doctor and
the master were forced to work together
for a little while there's just
something so interesting about enemies
forgetting that they're enemies so the
two big takeaways from this episode are
one don't trust carnivals and two robots
are still evil but the funny thing is is
there was actually a later Jon Pertwee
episode called carnival of monsters so
I'm sensing a theme there probably a lot
of Doctor Who writers that did not like
carnivals and carnival folk number two
the curse of Fenric my only seventh
doctor storing the list but a really
awesome mashup of zombie and vamp
prior stories it ends up turning to this
classic situation where scientist gets
too clever supercomputer they design
let's ancient evil loose and everything
goes crazy I think that's why the doctor
always tells people not to touch buttons
when they're in the TARDIS something
always goes wrong whenever you turn on
mysterious machines or read ancient
runes so lesson learned if you ever find
yourself waking up in a Doctor Who story
don't read anything and don't touch
anything just stand there and real still
and just do whatever the doctor says and
my number one favorite scary Doctor Who
episode the caves of Androzani just one
of the best episodes of classic who in
general but every time I see Jack I
think about Scorpius from Farscape it's
just so visually scary to look at and on
top of that Jack is this really put upon
tragic villain who forces the doctor to
sacrifice himself to save his companion
so it all just gets really weepy and sad
it was the final Peter Davison episode
so it did feature the regeneration into
a Colin Baker 6 dr. so now it's your
turn let me know what is your favorite
scary episode of Doctor Who it doesn't
have to be classic ooh it can totally be
a new episode but one that you just
think is really really scary so like I
said I will be at a town on Saturday but
I'll be back on Sunday for all my Game
of Thrones videos so you can follow me
on Instagram or Twitter I'll definitely
be posting some fun bonus content
nothing too crazy though because I will
be in Vegas and what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas
unless you post it to the Internet right
now though you can actually click here
to learn more about the master may be
coming back in series 8 and you can
click here to learn all about Danny pink
the new Doctor Who character thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
this weekend high fives
you